musician Andrew W K has been called the
great unwashed rock star and the great
god of partying since he first hit the
charts with the release of his 2001
album I get wet which featured the
anthemic Tunes hardy hard we want fun
and fun night
Rolling Stone praised the album as the
loudest and funniest metal you've heard
in ages and the Allmusic site pronounced
that resistance to it's hard partying
charms is futile born in 1979 and raised
in Ann Arbor Michigan Andrew W K has
also delighted a generation of children
as the host of destroy bill destroyed a
live-action Cartoon Network series in
which teams of kids compete for the
right to blow up each other's creations
he's a regular on Fox News red eyed with
greg gutfeld
and is not show up on channels ranging
from mtv to CNN to Glenn Beck TV he's
also a motivational speaker and through
his weekly ask Andrew W K column in the
Village Voice arguably the greatest
advice columnist working in the u.s.
today reason TV sat down to talk with
Andrew W K about his book and progress
the party boggle his new kids show on
maker TV meet me at the wreck and his
unabashed and unapologetic embrace of
fun and libertine abandon Andrew W K
thanks for talking to I'm thrilled to be
here thank you dick what's up with the
party well it's something fun to do and
that's what attracted me and I imagine
most folks to it out of all the things I
could imagine spending my time doing I
figure if I was going to devote myself
to a mission or dedicate my life to a
cause it should be an enjoyable one and
partying was the most fun thing I could
think of and also that other people
could relate to were you walking down
the street and almost got hit by a
falling safe for something full of
pinatas yeah and party favors no
unfortunately that would have been much
more dramatic but also painful so I'm
glad that it didn't involve injury no it
was I moved to New York when I was 18
from Michigan from Ann Arbor Michigan
there I had done all kinds of stuff but
decided not to go to college and move to
the biggest city I could think of right
and try to do something big and from
that emerged a lot of confusion a lot of
disappointments a lot of dead-end jobs
and sort of oddball experiences and then
at one point I got this ID
that I could sort of cheer myself up and
maybe cheer other people up because that
was really the reason I wanted to do
something were you I mean were you in a
depressed state yes yeah what was the
nature of that just a kind of
coming-of-age dislocation was it a
chemical imbalance probably wolf a
mixture of all those things anything
that felt bad I experienced some version
of it it never got overwhelming that
where I couldn't function at all and
I've seen and had friends that had
suffered from that level of depression
there was just a lot of anger a lot of
anger a lot of animosity towards the
world around me which I do think is part
of maybe that coming of age you you're
starting to call BS on a lot of stuff
and realize that you can and it's quite
thrilling to do so but I also realize
there was times I didn't feel like that
I felt quite good and I wanted to figure
out how I could feel like that more of
the time in one of the Village Voice
columns that you wrote somebody had
written in something along the lines oh
hey what's up with the partying and I
want to read a quote from you in that
you talked about the very nature of
partying is to provide a life-saving
release from the constant pressure to
quote take things seriously unquote I'm
having a party to celebrate life and you
talk about partying as an end in itself
now this is radical and subversive in an
age where you're not allowed to smoke
anymore you're not supposed to do drugs
you're not supposed to exercise too much
or too little
you're not supposed to fat or you know
not trans fat or not carbs no gluten you
know where does this end and what kind
of pushback do you get against the idea
of partying I would say no this is from
my perspective being in the middle of
the party and attracting and certainly
hanging out with a lot of people that
are also into partying it seems like
most people are relieved to have someone
tell them it's okay and that they have
that more than been fighting against
these kinds of pleasure themselves
they've been wanting to engage them but
just being made to feel very guilty
about it and I think it's just such a
great release for all of us to be able
to say hey I'm thinking about this stuff
too I'm doing this stuff too and I'm
actually enjoying it not feeling bad if
I can be a role model in that way I
never thought I would be a role model
for anything but a role model for fun I
can do that you have hosted a couple of
kid shows I mean the great destroyed
destroy which explained the premise for
some of the one or two viewers who
haven't seen this with the sort of the
the structure that we're on right now
talking about fun I mean this was a very
subversive show that I didn't didn't
necessarily set out to be but a lot of
explosions and in fact there had never
been that level of destruction and young
people in such close proximity on TV and
so it's I mean this is a competition
show game show yeah there's two two
teams of kids and they destroy a bunch
of stuff usually blowing it up then they
build something exactly and then the
winner of the competition gets to
destroy the other person's that other
team side and these were really big
explosions and we had tanks and we had
bazookas but I thought isn't this great
that we're using weaponry purely for fun
you know just for the spectacle like a
fireworks show and that isn't it
satisfying especially as a kid - you
know if you're riding a school bus every
day to school blow up the school bus now
that of course was very offensive - and
frightening to other people as well but
certainly none of the kids they thought
that was awesome because you can have
fun blowing something up and it doesn't
have to be violent yeah and this puts me
in mind of you toward not too long ago
with Marky Ramone in the great movie
rock and roll high school I mean that
ends with the destruction of Vince
Lombardi huh yeah
in it is it's like unthinkable you would
never be allowed to play that yeah I
mean are we in a particularly sour
period where people just don't want to
allow that excess a pleasure or a fun or
of unbridled ecstasy I would like to
think that there's been waves of this we
certainly have seen more button-down
eras before we came off maybe a high
point of a free open-minded thinking and
exuberance that now we're maybe
retreating from again maybe that's just
the ebb and flow of human nature but
also there are people that want to do
things in life and then there are people
that don't know what they want to do so
I think they think telling other people
what they're doing is what they end up
doing sort of you know like if someone
is excitement is to create a song and
someone else can't come up with a song
maybe their thrill is to tell someone
else what they think about their song on
a very passionate level that even
involves you know impacting that
person's ability to
get that song out and I thought well
maybe you know this adds more dialogue
maybe doesn't have to you know trample
on anyone's party because no one's
actually been able to stop me from
partying so far and you own or you
operate a Santos party house which is a
party facility it is this is a in in and
I mean I guess it went up in Mike
Bloomberg's New York of all things so
it's kind of like you're striking blows
against the Empire and it was not easy I
mean we were this was a concert hall and
music venue dance club but it was the
first brand-new meaning we built it it
wasn't just moving into someone else's
club and changing the name we built this
place in scratch got all the liquor
license got the cabaret license and
explain why a cabaret license is is
better than just a you know a bargain
you can dance
there's laws that prohibit dancing and
they will crack down on them and they
will come in and if someone is moving
their body in a rhythmic way even if
you're walking with too much passion
then you're breaking the law because
you'll have a cabaret license so we got
the cabaret license and that was a huge
that was the biggest work that we had to
do was just getting the licenses but I
think also it's sort of like a maze as a
labyrinth the challenge and ordeals to
weed out the people that really aren't
capable of of running a party house is
that really mean so that's how I
interpret okay so you're not just saying
like well you know what the hell is this
I mean I always try to find a less
frustrating way to look at things so I
thought well this was like our running
the gamut we had to prove that we had
what it took to run a party house and
maybe you have to go through these these
steps to show that you're serious talk
you know you and I would like around
2005 or so you decided that just to be a
music maker and a concert maker but you
wanted to be a motivational speaker yes
explain a little bit where that came
from and then also talk about your your
events I mean you're kind of lectures
oftentimes I don't want to say devolve I
guess they evolved it readable well one
of the things I mean to me it's it's
almost like you know it's like a
performance art piece from a Fluxus
artist in the early 60s it's a happening
it's not a lecture anymore and it's not
answered you know what's going on with
that well it is it's much like this
being in a room together that's how I
thought if it is we're in a room
together and
after that we'll sort of see what
happens I don't really think that his
performance are out of respect for
people I've seen who actually are
performance artists I'm not trained in
that or really even interested in
personally cuz I don't have that skill
but I thought there are people out there
that for whatever reason it's hard for
me to fathom but they they don't like
loud music or they don't like rock music
and I've met those people that said I
read something that you did an interview
or I saw a TV clip and it connected with
me and they got the same feeling that I
was getting and trying to get other
people to feel through music they were
getting through words and I thought this
counts this is another way and my main
focus was that feeling of physical joy
that that hands over your head I
couldn't possibly feel better this is
why I'm alive feeling and if I can get
that feeling conjured up through talking
or doing an interview like this then I
figured that it you know it's not
working for me although I do want to
thank you for passing up probably both
this is nice yeah you're right yes this
is spy versus spy absolutely let me ask
you about the party Bible which is a
book that you're under contract you're
on the hook for when are we going to say
that I have been writing this book in
earnest for about the last year and I'm
now in the the crunch time like this is
the homestretch I have to get it done in
the next few weeks the first book I've
ever written it's not an autobiography
in any stretch I'm actually trying to
eliminate anecdotal any sort of content
and really make it talking about life
through the lens of partying and doing
my advice column is giving me a lot of
great feedback but certainly just
practice writing and practice writing
about things that I haven't even thought
of that much and I almost feel like I am
channeling like it feels like it's a
reverse ghost writing process I feel
like someone else is telling me what to
write versus me telling them so it's
been a month I think I've seen this
movie it's called The Shining it doesn't
end nice yeah it's not that frightening
and it's not that sister can you party
too much or what what is the role of
either moderation or balance in a in a
world of partying and of kind of
exuberant joy well you don't want to die
that's pretty much the threshold but
with that being said out of respect for
people that
gone all the way to the edge and then
you know died I wouldn't say that they
messed up maybe that's what they wanted
to do you miss them and you wish they
were still there but you celebrate what
they left behind them I want to be able
to party for as long as possible and so
I that's the one thing I always thought
was you know identify your limits push
past them to a degree to create a new
limit like exercise expand your soul and
that can be a painful process but then
your body recovers your soul expands but
you don't need to kill yourself having
fun because that hurts let's talk about
the the village Royce column asked
Andrew W K comes out every week in the
Village Voice somebody asks you to talk
about a procrastination they said I have
a problem with procrastination and you
managed to turn this I mean you are mr.
upbeat and optimistic you're always
looking for the you know a lesson to be
learned as opposed to a pain to be
suffered and you talked about how
procrastination is not necessarily a bad
thing and it takes a while to get into
whatever you're doing in it you said
discomfort as a small price to pay for
brilliance you know what what do you
what are you getting at with that well
sometimes the torment of wrestling with
productivity with work in general
whether it's very tedious work or
whether it's very esoteric work that
demands the kind of higher mind that
isn't easy to access practicing piano
for example that was hell for me I
learned piano lessons starting around
age four and a half and just thinking
about everything from having to the
recitals and the tests to the lessons
themselves and then especially practice
was torturous but I can tell you I
wouldn't be sitting here doing anything
or talking about anything had I not gone
through that so I'm not saying that I am
the most brilliant piano player but the
suffering that I went through in that
ordeal certainly rewarded me and so I
think you know struggling with work you
have to sort of just take that as par
for the course if you're going to do
good work it's not going to feel good
all the time and you know at the core of
a lot of year
your activities there's there's this
incredible empathy which is you know I
find phenomenal in a column that a
person wrote in about saying like you
know what's with white privilege wire
you know people attacking you know
people for having white privilege other
people saying no that's [ __ ] and you
wrote in the context of a long and
interesting response you said love it's
never naive compassion is never
inappropriate love and compassion make
life livable where where do you where is
that thought coming from in you that's
coming from again me trying to cheer
myself up and me trying to retain some
sort of humanity and sanity in my own
life having people that I'm angry at
having people I don't relate to and then
having people tell me no but there's a
there's there's certain people that you
should never have any love for or
compassion for it and I can understand
what they mean like very extreme
examples like a killer or something but
what if I could still find some way to
not feel that hatred towards them and
that that's a worthwhile mindset in fact
to keep very close and upfront your mind
is that I mean is the party as a concept
because I mean you can party by yourself
but then you more often than not you've
run the risk of being Michael Hutchence
or David Carradine right you're alone in
a closet somewhere or the party is kind
of a hive mind or it's almost an
organism that is made up of individual
cells of people yeah but it's also
throbbing and pulsing so it almost seems
like there's always a social dimension
to partying and in your kind of
cosmology well yes I like the idea that
you can be an individual that's part of
a group of individuals and a friend of
mine who actually has become a very
successful for real philosopher he was
talk about the word party and how it
essentially came from the root word
partay or partition which is to actually
remove yourself from a larger group to
identify with people in a specific way
in a closer not necessarily than
celebratory way but just you know as a
party of like-minded individuals but you
can you know there's something very
funny and paradoxical a paradoxical
about that you're celebrating a
collective feeling by removing yourself
from a larger collective group and
ultimately I do think a party of one is
sort of the strongest mindset or that is
what this is getting at that
you can party with people that you don't
know at all I have nothing in common
with and you can party completely by
yourself with the understanding that
other people are out there doing the
same thing I'm someone who has felt left
out so I always wanted to try to draw
people
my biggest goal actually come out of
high school was to try to connect with
people that I didn't like that didn't
like me and to find someplace where we
had a common ground and that was that
party mindset talk a little bit about
your your childhood you're the son of
academics yeah you grew up in Ann Arbor
which means you suffered under going to
University of Michigan which as somebody
who graduated from Rutgers and recently
saw even Rutgers football can beat
Michigan these days even it's a horrible
place to be from but what was your
childhood I mean you know why were you
why did you feel so alienated well first
of all was a great place to grow up
because it was very radical and as far
as culture goes I mean I had access and
exposure to stuff that still blows my
mind and the more actually I've time I
spent away from where I grew up I
realized like that really was special so
I was very thankful for all the weirdos
and wackos and extreme people that I got
to encounter that showed me how vast the
world was it was it was like the exact
opposite of a sheltered childhood um but
I did I found myself very angry at a lot
of the college students but just sort of
this the general atmosphere of the
school I guess and that's maybe why I
didn't go to college even though my dad
still is a professor and he said look I
teach college it's no big deal he knew
from firsthand experience that I didn't
have to go but I think that did probably
push me away to find some other other
way of connecting with those people
without having to do it on their terms
you speaking of fathers in a great
column from a little while ago a person
wrote in saying my dad is a right-wing
[ __ ] the brighter went on to say like
he can't stand his father anymore and
that he loves his father but his
father's politics are so awful and you
responded by that of like saying hey you
have to step back and I quote the world
is being destroyed by one side believing
the other side is destroying the world
so again there's a push towards empathy
what about Isis what about Islamic
radicals who are beheading people you
know how do you how do you deal with
that in the real world well I think that
you know fortunately there is a way to
apply even these most extreme AI
potentially idealist or even naive ways
of thinking to the real world I think
even in that same response I said and if
we're put in a position where we have to
kill someone or or be killed
realize you're killing a human but
person probably much like you and it's
just that's what it has come to I think
it's when we what really is bothered me
is when someone says like that person's
a monster sort of alluding to that
there's no part of me that has anything
to do with that human that I would never
even be capable of it and I think we're
all capable of all kinds of things
there's mental illness there's people
that are wired differently but I want to
be able to relate to that person and and
feel good that I didn't choose to do
those are there particular writers or
artists I mean we mentioned the Ramones
briefly you know who are your influences
in this kind of thing because actually
in talking with you I do get a sense the
Ramones are like that where they
simultaneity were
what it meant to be a pinhead what it
meant to be you know what [ __ ] what it
meant to be a male prostitute you know I
mean there's an interesting you know
attempt to kind of empathize or to show
a world that people don't have any
sympathy for marginalised yeah well it's
the in-between spaces people that occupy
those in-between spaces that are neither
this nor that they ultimately just
become themselves they're one-off people
and that's always been who I'm most
interested in I mean probably my biggest
Idol is Santa Claus because there's no
one else like him everyone is familiar
with it you don't even have to believe
in him to believe in what that he exists
in this this idea and they cheered
people up and yet he's completely of
himself you know and yet there could
even be a million sinners you know it's
it's it's a state of mind so I liked
that idea and anyone who is able to to
truly be themselves and carve out enough
space in between everyone else you know
they always get me excited athletes you
know musicians writers magicians anyway
who are the musicians that have really
fired up your creative juices well I
like all kinds of music but the ones I
have to give credit to my piano teachers
because that was the first time I ever
felt anything about probably anything
the first time I had an orgasmic feeling
it was actually when they would play
every lesson they would show me what
they were working on and that that's
what kept me going to these lessons to
hear them playing at that level and I
would get chills up and down my body I
would get this feeling that I never got
before and after a while a few times I
said wait a minute this isn't a fluke
like this happens from music this
happens from things in life like this is
a this means I like this thing I mean
that's how primitive my thinking was um
and and trying chasing after that
feeling and trying to create it over and
over and over again and hopefully for
other people too that's that's joy
that's my mission joy boy it now is the
joy boy the real you you're willing to
you know try on different mass or
different identities and different
circumstance we go through different
phases and you're kind of conscious of
that do you think that that is more
common these days I mean or people you
know as they get you know Millennials
Gen X baby boomers maybe there's more of
a sense of play of like okay well I can
try on this identity for a while and see
how the world looks from it and is that
again I mean play in general and playing
with yourself in every way where this is
we can cut that out oh no please don't
the playing with your own life yeah is
about as good as it gets and being able
to see your life as something that can
be played with and that that in fact
that's the most respectful way to take
advantage of this gift of being alive in
the world you know I I strongly believe
in that the idea of maybe what you're
getting at with with maybe authenticity
and things I don't you know I like
processed existence things that have
been worked over and fine-tuned to make
them more exciting I like processed food
I don't find you know a plain vegetable
as interesting as one that's been
processed I like that people have worked
very hard to make this experience for me
that they've manipulated it you know I
like a show I like life to be that I can
look at the air and see it as
for what it is or I can you know in jest
ear that's has different molecules in it
and it makes me feel different so I like
it all
but I think it is scary to think that
that somehow a more boring life is
somehow more noble right and more
authentic if you're just like this is
like everything counts everything is
real good you know in that same 2009
interview you had talked about how when
you were in a building kind of the
Andrew W K kind of stage show or
presence or persona that you said that
it was done in the spirit of
entertainment which usually goes hand in
hand with Commerce and this may be from
an older generation of artists there
always seem to be a lot of hand-wringing
about oh my god if we're successful
we're selling out or there was the idea
that you could either do pure art or be
a sellout that doesn't seem to have any
standing in your universe and it seems
to be liberating yes
and I had a lot of friends that felt the
the same way as you're describing that
it was bad to make money or want money
but I just very early on I wanted to do
things that required money to do whether
it was go on tour with a full band and
be able to pay them or you know produce
a video that looked the way I wanted it
to look but also and this was even more
important to me I was attracted to the
sheen of highly produced content or art
or whatever you want to call it the
world I appreciated you know again like
going on a pony ride that was fun in a
way but I would much rather gone on a
roller coaster you know a really big
roller coaster that just appealed to me
I liked movie posters that looked like
it took you know six or seven hours just
to get that shot and to manipulate it
and to create a logo that looks really
really striking not just something that
was handwritten cast off that was just
my aesthetic
I liked things that involved high
production so you know I like TV I like
advertisements I just like the way they
look I like the way they feel and it
never was the music I made was made to
be used that way it was made to be
played at a sporting event you know that
wasn't me the biggest compliment was
having my song on that you know on a
football game or on a basketball game
was something where at a baseball
stadium everyone singing along that to
me was like I might
bhima's come true do you feel like we're
in a particularly great moment for kind
of art and of the sort that you're
talking about creativity in that the
tools of production are cheaper now I
mean you know obviously there's still
out of the reach of a lot of people but
you can do in your home studio now what
the Beatles couldn't do at Abbey Road
yeah in their heyday you know book
publishing art manipulation distribution
by the internet I mean is this a
particularly rich moment for that
and if so does that does that create
more of an interest in that kind of
aesthetics of people realizing that
objects don't just happen they're made
and you have to take a high craft them
yeah uh well first it was very
threatening because I was right in the
middle I I my I was signed to Universal
Music Group in Island Def Jam
you know like 99 mm right as things were
changed over right as Napster was
starting and I got to experience the
tail end where we had budgets that were
just so big that we could go back to Sri
shoot one scene in a music video for
tens of thousands of dollars where now I
wouldn't even get one percent you know a
regular video net would cost one percent
of just the reshoot day and you'd be
lucky to get that so was really
interesting to see that transition but
also see that well I don't even need
that much money to film this because I
can do it within sight inside the
computer with two people instead of 200
the only thing I didn't like about that
was there was some kind of price it was
a feeling you were winning a prize if
you got access to work with that version
of the industry because it was so
rarefied and once anyone could get those
tools it kind of took away the feeling
like ah I worked so hard to get in there
but then you realize you know it wasn't
that great inside there anyway is there
a politics to partying you know by that
I you know not necessarily are you a
Democrat or a Republican a liberal or
conservative but is there is there an
ideology here that threatens you know
the status quo or leans in one direction
or another now that I have seen and I've
been very thankful and I've been nervous
at times that any whenever politics
would come up or sort of values and
morals and ethics if that ever became
part of the conversation that
automatically people would
because they wouldn't agree or someone
else would just say I didn't want this
to to involve you know that kind of
thinking I can't be a part of this I've
been very very surprised and delighted
that this party has enough room for all
kinds of stuff for pretty much all modes
of thinking for all modes of people and
it seems like people enjoy again having
a space having a mindset where you don't
have to pick aside all the time or have
an opinion about every single thing or
every person so would you what would be
your ultimate party would it be that you
know it starts out and Dick Cheney as
I've run this side of the room and
Barack Obama and as Kenyan socialists
are on the other and by the end they're
in a full clinch in the middle that I
vow that could be an incredible movie
just seeing that played out I don't
think so but a lot CGI well you know you
you do a wide variety of shows you talk
to pretty much everybody or a regular on
red eye the great Greg Gutfeld Fox News
Channel show you know do people look at
that and they say oh you're on Fox News
what you know what's going on you've
done the weather on Fox yes as a matter
of fact and you you've had a great
conversation with Glenn Beck yes very
recently oh yeah every now and then
someone will say what are you doing on
there and I say I was invited and that
usually ends the conversation you know I
go where I'm invited I have no animosity
towards everybody toward any particular
group that's that vast I mean these are
huge organizations as well people have
been nice to me you know that's another
thing that means a lot that makes it
very easy to go and hang out with
someone even if you don't agree on every
single thing even when my band formed I
didn't barely even know a lot of the
people I was working with and I had to
find common ground a lot of them grew up
in very different ways in totally
different parts of the country they had
different backgrounds but we would
connect on something like a song or on a
certain movie we liked and that was
enough to be able to get through the day
and I didn't we didn't I didn't go into
all the other stuff that we didn't agree
on or that we couldn't relate to we just
picked what we could get along with and
then the party kept going well let's end
it with tell me what's the best way to
watch meet me at the wreck which is kind
of your latest thank you enterprise
maybe of the records or new kids show in
it's a project base so it's short clips
that you can watch all you know back to
back but each one has a project at
activity you can learn and it's on maker
TV also on YouTube but it's on demand
and it's all out now there's a pisode
with Jack Black and his son with a
goalie explore minecraft you know this
amazing world of professional video
games we have Zach woods who is from the
office he played the character gay but
now he's in Silicon Valley another
amazing show Bobby Lee who's an amazing
comedian so it's a lot of fantasy some
almost supernatural elements but it all
adds up to hopefully a very entertaining
TV party well as a final as a parting
thought I mean you're very optimist
about the future we live in a world
where people are constantly predicting
the end or that the future is going to
be much worse than it is now
what can you leave us with a happy
upbeat thought the world is always
ending and it's always beginning and if
we're able to keep love and a
celebratory sense of making the most of
what we can with what we have right now
I think that's all we have to do what we
will we will leave it there with Andrew
W K the great unwashed rock star for
Reason TV I'm Nikolas